want to just bring you some breaking
news we're getting from los angeles
concerning the
golfer tiger woods and there it is for
you it's a statement from the la county
sheriff's department uh
you can read it for yourself i mean it's
in uh police language of course
and uh it says that uh on february the
23rd as you can see
uh at early in the morning 7 12 a.m
the los angeles sheriff's department
responded to a vehicle rollover
collision
on the border of the rolling hills
estates and the vehicle was traveling
northbound that's the direction but it's
the
the next paragraph uh that really
matters the end of it says the vehicle
sustained major damage
the driver and sole occupant was
identified as eldrick
tiger woods mr woods was extricated from
the wreck
with the jaws of life by los angeles
county firefighters and paramedics and
then transported to a local hospital by
ambulance for his
injuries the traffic investigation is
being conducted by investigators
from lasd lomita station so no
information there about the condition
of tiger woods but the fact that the
so-called jaws of life
had to be used this is one of those
devices that prizes a
wrecked vehicle apart means that uh
tiger woods was presumably trapped in
some way shape or form
in that vehicle it's a story we're
monitoring for you but at the moment all
we have is that statement from the
la county sheriff's department the tiger
woods has been in
a sole vehicle uh accident uh a roll
over as the
l a sheriff's department has described
it and has had to be rescued from the
vehicle and
is now being taken to hospital condition
unknown
you